getting connected
right good morning
members of the community resources
committee other members president
and
members of the public listening on
youtube
and hopefully a short meeting but we'll
see how we go
item one apologies for absent
yes
councillor bright counsellor and cancer
diet
item two minutes of the community and
resources committee of the 6th of june
it was a short meeting so the minutes
are reasonably short
i will check them through page
at the bottom page three
four
five
yes in reference to the motion
uh
that's on there the um
have we had any updated tour from
southwest water
because we did have one of those items
on there one of the bullet points about
the sewage pollution uh the surcharging
and uh that was raised at the external
ons
southwest water did a presentation and
it wasn't very good and there were a lot
of unanswered questions you got no
feedback from that
well i've heard nothing uh steve says
it's a different i need to say it's a
different accent to this notice of
motion chair
that's something here this is councillor
hudson's notice emotion for the ocean
that's right but it does say on page
four on the third bullet point down
that water continuing our asteroid
polluting
heavy rain storms which is to do with
surcharging and that was a specific
point that i ran the board over one of
the points look forward to the ons
meeting
and
and i do think we need to respond for
that because one of the other things
i was speaking to an experienced
environmental officer
uh last week
and um you know one of the
myths
actually is that a lot of the pollution
in our rivers
is caused by agriculture not true
actually
human sewage that's causing the problems
the major part of the problem inclusion
in our rivers
tom chair we'll take it as an action but
i do believe that southwest water
responded
um in writing with all answers that were
not answered at the meeting and they
were circulated but i'll double check
that after me and like yeah every word
i can't report getting that term
yeah i don't know if it helps councilman
brenton but i'm putting forward a motion
asking that when planning applications
come in on united states
one southwest water just right back and
say no problem we will ask them what
might be the effects on the possible
surcharging and the dumping of waste
into the sea because it goes on now and
yet here we are building more and more
houses and i would like to know the
impact of that um again what is the
carrying capacity of cornbread we can
never find that out
so there is emotion coming forward
well i i personally have a degree of
sympathy you go back
15 years ago
and a very large number of plumbing
applications were turned down because it
wasn't the sewage capacity
now it's not doesn't seem to be a ground
to turn anything down
and i don't see that much money having
been spent on the facilities but here we
are
we'll move on any other comments we're
on page five
[Music]
six
so they can be treated as correct
and we have no problem oh cancer no no
i'm just going to put a second and a few
of the proposals thank you all proposed
seconded all in favor
up to
uh
five
that's against
abstentions
to
seven
oh my
name
okay we move on to
agenda item three public contributions
we have none
[Music]
agenda item for
forward plan it is written it's on page
7
anyone wishing to add anything to it
nope
proper job
agenda item
5
[Music]
is declarations of interest you're all
big boys and girls now you don't need
that explained
except that for members of the public if
a councillor is involved in something
financially or practically we have to
declare it to this council
item six agreement of the agenda between
parts one and two there's nothing
in part two so that shouldn't be a
problem
item seven urgent matters
to bring forward i have none
item eight four to six hubberstone road
conversion to hospital hospital
accommodation
of properties owned by the council
accommodation and then to make the
physical alterations to both for and by
the concealed accommodation so members
will be aware that down at capital
pushdot we own two prodigies that were
converted into stock crystals those
there are the entrance to the patient
oxide they're currently left there's
office space but as you can see in the
report only you have some small income
not particularly popular as on its
foundation
the report also describes your pressing
need to solve the financial problems we
have in relation to emergency
accommodation and how uh hostile
accommodation seems to be the answer for
that
we've previously been in discussion
about the conversion of these buildings
hence the planning application for five
cobblestone institute accommodation for
uh with holland wolf on of foreign
business in ecuador and they've got
problems with the accommodating staff
and they wanted to convert this as sort
of dormitory accommodation for their
facilities in light of the fact that the
financial issues we are experiencing
ourselves the under use of those
facilities we've actually uh brought the
report to you saying we consider it more
pressing that we convert them for our
own purposes rather than for her in the
world but i have actually communicated
that to
as it stands
the financials associated associated
with it are included within the report
david's hopefully
putting up
an estimate of how it's going to cost to
convert and how quickly we pay back and
i think share that that's it in a
nutshell uh moves us to the
recommendation
counselor brentwood
thank you
um going back to the 1990s when tory
bought these uh properties
i was vice chair of policy can you
believe that never mind um
because
of the fear of
the noise
pollution
and how the the owners of these
properties i think it was four there was
four isn't there altogether i think
there's three in the terrace and we have
two of them
it was a major threat that they were
going to close the shipyard because of
the noise pollution
and so torridge uh decided to buy them
and i think but one of the owners
wouldn't buy but
legally it meant that they they didn't
ever let the stand on if they went off
to say that they uh
the shipyard was making too much noise
so at the same time
and expressed purpose of blocking that
that attempt to close the shipyard
because of the noise i think it's a good
idea to do this you know
except my only caveat would be that
whoever moves in there we i think we
must have a tenancy agreement which says
that you you're taking it is in other
words that you will go your
your opportunity to complain about the
noise
can that be done
it's going to be used for temporary
accommodation so they want to license
effectively and that they're put in
there once we try and find permanent
accommodation so that the the whole
premise behind this is to say booking
them into a travel launch or a baby it's
i mean i i wouldn't admit our temporary
accommodation is going on longer but
it's not ever supposed to be a permanent
investment so we don't actually give
tenancy agreements for what they're
gonna license arrangement
so in other words they wouldn't have a
longer long period of time to accumulate
a history of just poisoning right okay
yeah that's that's fine
counselor christine yeah i'm gonna
propose we do this but i've got one
question in our figures
they said running costs
fifty thousand five and eight months
i mean what are those running costs a
thousand pounds a week
that will be an estimated cost based on
the hospital accommodation that
elsewhere within the
council's portfolio will include repairs
and maintenance or include utilities
and it will include probably business
rates as well because the premises will
be licensed for business rates
cleaning
and sort of
caretaker type functions
still saves quite a lot of thousand
pounds a week well it's based
on what would cost the salt costs we
incur
uh in our other hospitals
of a similar nature i mean it's very
much an estimate on that maybe maybe
slightly overstated but because
thing let's say you read the national
financial figures is that this is a very
effective way of providing temporary
accommodations actually
income generating them being fruitful
rather than actually incurring costs of
producing the premium and also keep
people at risk of homelessness
local rather because sometimes we're
putting people in
the accommodation outside of the
council's boundaries
thank you well i have proposed it but
could i just ask that in a year's time
you get an updated figure what
[Music]
nine
uh
paragraph two the very final paragraph
planning
uh surely this is dometic development
well yeah but the rules have changed
from this is
offices to residential which is pd
surely
generally this is hostile accommodation
which is slightly different and i think
it was only last was probably only six
months ago that we considered the
previous application so we can check
whether the rules have changed in the
past six months but the standard advices
that have been application
right counselor
thank you chair um
just to answer sort of running costs
obviously hospitals have to be furnished
as well so there are the associated
costs
we um furniture replacements and repairs
absolutely so it's important to
definitely make that i think just
throughout i think some of the running
costs might also include the cost of
financing yes
thank you um
now completely
that would be good
um that's right my main point was that i
think this committee needs to know the
uh
top of page nine
uh that we are being proactive and
discussing we're far and more
the possibility
of um
them housing
dormitory accommodation on their site
and i think that's really important that
we're seen to be
not just
meeting our own needs but we're actually
facilitating and going one step further
to work and engage with harland moore
so i think that is
a good practice
and i welcome that intervention
the only comment is that that's not the
council of leather and his committee we
have no power over there
chancellor bushby
thank you chairman um
probably mentioned this before but have
you got any idea of
people that are going to be using this
emergency accommodation
and all the local people that are on our
books now that we just can't accommodate
or are they
people that are going to be moving into
the area from uh from the way you know
because i see this as you know it's a
never-ending story and it's it's it
almost seems like it's something that we
will never ever be able to you know to
give it a practice because you know as
more and more and more people move into
the area
that have the means to house themselves
they end up on the council's doorstep
and then we end up having to provide
them emergency accommodation and it
seems to me that you know we could
if we if he cured the whole thing in
one thousand
in one month the following month it
would start again the whirling end
when we're not providing emergency
accommodation for
individuals
or for focus
a very good question will it end
obviously the economic position of that
at the moment uh the cost of closing um
interest rates going up the cost of
living prices
because people we have a legal
requirement
um and
homelessness legislation
um generally there will be people within
the area
but obviously with some of the uh
schemes around homes for ukraine
there are individuals coming across into
the uk and ultimately some of those end
up with a house in responsibility for
torridge so there's no definitive answer
to your question sorry councilman i i
appreciate i've been
just replying to that i mean
taking deciding
the ukrainian issue which is obviously
a serious nature and you know
the refugees that are you know their
lives are only threatening some things
of that nature if you look back
to have done
not that long ago i mean you know six
seven years ago torrid was spending you
know
probably less than a hundred grand on
this type of accommodation now it's it's
around half a million where is it one of
them
that's because the room has changed
counselor but so i realized that
you know the cost of rental
accommodation in saudi arabia has driven
exponentially and your colleague willian
did a
report which will be shared at full
council may 15th september
regarding how much cost of accommodation
is going to compare with wages and
that's one of the factors that people
are finding difficult to have
sustainable tenancies so it's a market
factor as much as anything so four years
ago we probably could find people
accommodation in accommodation that was
roughly at the local housing allowance
road that is increasingly difficult not
impossible at the moment so we're
dealing with a market that is against us
so that's why the costs have gone up by
so much
i i appreciate the cost has gone up but
also the numbers have gone on
considerably so it's not just because
now
it was five or six years ago the actual
number of people that were housing has
also gone up massively my question
really that's because of the deployment
primarily because of the decline
in the affordable private events and
accommodation so people are finding they
come to the end of the tenancy so people
who have always granted they come to the
end of tennessee the landlord is selling
the property they're converting them to
a holiday for whatever reason that
property is no longer available they
then will go and look on the market to
see if they can find somewhere to
accommodate their family and find that
it's of their financial reach
that is why the numbers are primarily
going on
i'll rescue their chair as an argument
i'm certainly not really able to win
today
councillor newton
[Music]
are holiday monuments
and airbnb and so we know that's going
on why can't
and why can't we as a planning provider
say you are changing the domestic health
or business
i mean you've just heard from sure about
the place in uh epidural were changing
from domestic the hospital would seem
you know the difference but why can't we
do that and try and control this
chair that's a responsibility the
valuation of this agency will manage the
uh business rate and council tax
register so the
application doesn't come to tourist
figures the valuation office agency they
determine
which uh register the property appears
on there's a change of use and domestic
for business yes
so why don't they come to planning um
the evaluation office agency not the
responsibility of the planning authority
the next meeting when we've got a
statutory duty to house people because
we're very arguably held in people where
we have a legal duty to do so and i
think there kind of seems to be some
misconceptions
that we're housing people when we we
wouldn't have to and i can assure you
that that's not the case but
if i bring forward the next meeting when
we have a duty when we don't then that
might help inform members
uh chancellor hudson yeah i think it
will be useful too um stacy if we could
include
what um the housing options team do
with somebody who presents that's just
arrived with their suitcases
about reconnection
and actually the lengths that we can go
to to actually reconnect them from once
they came and return them to where there
would be a duty
because we wouldn't necessarily have a
duty to house them because it would be
seen as an intentional attack
so i think it's i think it's
understanding
what comes as prevention and what comes
as a statutory duty and i would welcome
that because i think it will
uh make it much cleaner
councillor leather
thank you chair but the question that
struck me when i had this
the other day
[Music]
providing this accommodation
[Music]
[Music]
i'm saying i'm canceled at this point
it's almost a perhaps kind of situation
where
it's going up and it's rocking you know
as well
the number of people that seem to be
needed from great accommodation
[Music]
and
it's a concern that the cost of doing
them they already own them
i just thought
you know a real
i realized it was kept on the tree they
don't just invest where they're going
um
i would say i'm not totally surprised
when councils get involved in building
it's always expensive because the rules
are followed in all respects
um
conversion alteration is expensive new
build is the cheapest way of building by
a mile if you can do it but we haven't
got the land we haven't got the sites
and we need to do something there's the
problem
and there's yeah so i was just going to
say i mean obviously we don't we don't
want to spend any more than we've got to
spend on this and we'll go to the market
and get the best
uh compliant price for the job
and actively manage the cost as much as
we can that the adrian is a sticker for
those types of things and chair was some
speaking
because he made a recommendation about
bringing back the costs of running the
building within 12 months given that
we've got a planning process to go
through and then the conversion it
wouldn't have been operating long within
12 months so maybe he'd stretch that
eight to eighteen months to make that
little meaningful as a figure
six months and then yeah but then we've
got to find builders and then we've got
to get the job done and say let's take a
while doesn't it
[Music]
we're
we have no control over the properties
um
is that right we just have no control
anybody provided a victory by two please
come to our door i mean when you look at
sexually saying central london
he's then
got a young family
why not come to college
give them a better standard of life and
the surprise being gloves isn't even
crazy
right i suspect we've
exhausted this discussion i'm going to
put it to the vote i have a proposal
under second or i believe
so all those in favor of the
recommendations we do it please show
that is unanimous thank you
so we now move on to the minutes of the
harbor board
oh sorry jump on
um
[Music]
urgency procedure
uh we've had to do a
couple capsules james myself
i don't know
right
okay so this
uh the urgency procedural demolition
from the energy rebate scheme and the
150
pounds that the government's contributed
towards um energy but it's running
through the council tax system so we
have a mandatory a to d scheme and then
we were given um commission to implement
a discretionary scheme for uh properties
in eta h
um so we wanted to get that rolled out
as soon as possible um and you'll see
the eligibility criteria at uh on page
19 at uh 0.3 um
so
we didn't want to do an application
system we haven't got the resources to
do that
and in line with the other authorities
we decided to implement a policy
for anyone who's ready to cancel tax
reduction support or in receipt of a
council tax exemption
um and so
they're really happy to take any any
questions whether we started on the
scheme out last week
for those in properties
i think from councilman james from my
point of view we sort of the no-brainer
we have to sign it and get on with it
[Music]
i
okay now we can move on
to
item
10
the minutes of the harbour board page 26
the 32
[Music]
there is one thing here at least that
needs discussion
um but i'm going to take them through
from the bottom pages first
and we'll no doubt stop when we come to
that item
page 26
27
28
29
[Music]
30
and at that point i'm gonna stop
because it's the item one two
6
councillor bushby's proposal
so i'm passing over to councillor bushby
with this one all right thank you
well as you as you can read there this
is a proposal beside um
a mobile
poppy ban
opposite g22
but if we key on the the seaward side of
the wall uh a property van
a short period of time in the
summer months with some cables and
chairs outside
to capture the trade that
moves uh all over that area of the king
i mean this weekend it would have been
very useful having the water festival
there as well thank you
i think it's a it's a good idea i'll
certainly give a lot of support as uh i
think most people on the arbor board
were in agreement that
we support this application and indeed i
would personally support most others
that come forward to make a better use
of the area of the key to actually earn
a little bit of revenue from tolerance
if you cancel
authorities rather you know to
help fund the 101 things that this
country has to
provide funding for
and they're not sure thank you
right there you are that's the proposal
canceling it
could i ask chad what's the what are the
arrangements for
other vendors in similar situations on
council land is it a question of them
applying for a license in order to train
or is it
actually our operation that we're
putting there
so so chair i'm not sure you need a
resolution today because i think after
harvard board what actually happened was
we agreed at hoverboard we agreed we
tried two month period where we worked
out whether this was
an option for future years if it turns
out it's a success because
i would wholeheartedly support a report
back to cnr to establish a more
permanent use of that space um then i
think obviously you have a chance to
decide in those in that
uh circumstance yes i think there'll
have to be a market uh led competitive
process for establishing google pbn
[Music]
in this particular instance we were
approached by a company that wanted to
try it
took a paper to harvard board basically
saying should we give this a go on a
two-month basis to see whether it's
going for future years the harvard
board's view was by the majority i don't
think universally supported
that um
it's uh
getting a go for two months and if it
does work we'll come back to you as a
committee to establish it's useful
okay council of laws yes
it's something i wanted to raise but
we've not been in the position because
of coving
um when coverage struck the government
[Music]
i have a family member that's in this
situation
we support them and let them use some of
our plans which has worked very well
um
now kobe's team with whole power is over
yeah so this is this is relates to a
different matter in westwood hope that
that particular circumstance i don't
think they would qualify for a pavement
license we do issue paper licenses now
we used to be a county function but it
was devolved to us during the coping
crisis to try and increase the wheels
from us um i don't think we would issue
a patient and pay a paper license in
that location being that you'd be
serving across a road to a premises i
think the risks would be too high and so
what we need to do is consider whether
those benches continue in their current
way that they're working you know it
seems to be the people going from the
shop to the other uh to the bench to
sydney and look at the safety of that
arrangement if you're not going to
venture at all
thank you
council brandon
um
i can't see anywhere in this report
which said that the uh the the
activities of the fishing
people should take precedence over any
sort of trading activities there there
have been times when they had some big
vehicles down there in order to service
uh the trawlers
and of course the oldenburg as well as
from time to time had to have um
big trucks in there to get stuff off to
londy i presume that that would be
written in that the harbor activities
would take precedence over there so on
those days it wouldn't be
the time that they would have to uh
not operate
so substantive going to the the court
meeting when we sort of started at the
trial the harbour master has been in uh
discussions with all of the users of
that commercial area there have been
some concerns raised by the
predominantly ultimate uh the london
company about fueling and things like
that and they're working through risk
assessments and method statements to
make sure that these things can sort of
cohabit safely right okay that's good
thank you the other question is to do
with the apprentice
uh it's just dragged on for a long time
i thought this year perhaps with the
platinum jubilee and then
i don't know why they
allowed to
discontinue i think he worked at about
45 pence working
back in the day but it hasn't happened
it also brings to mind that i've noticed
in one of our you know
first magazine that we get as memphis
and one of the towns up north one uh by
the end of the government for restoring
the high street what did they do with
their main feature
you know we got one they're sitting
there doing nothing you know and i do
think
we're trying to
enhance the place that uh there's no
good
the funding for the replacement of the
parts for the fountain was uh discussed
as part of the counter programming a few
years back and the budget was removed
and then the members agreed to remove
that from the capital
[Music]
it was removed from the capital program
i'd probably say this is maybe three
years ago
i remember events
if you read page thirties i can follow
has been received it will be brought to
the group for discussion
so have we asked for that
that might have superseded uh what david
was referring to some years ago that
capital figures with the program
hopefully there's
seems to be some discussion since then
about
[Music]
it might be something that harvard must
have been doing
[Music]
and i do remember three years ago what
quite expensive
uh figure we had them but we always used
to feature these fountains in all our
publicity tourism everything and it
seems weird that we can't actually
readdress this um the other thing about
the um
mobile cafe sort of things going on
there uh i voted for it although again i
have to share an interest the people
behind it they're in british property
uh
but
i hope this will be the start of
clearing
the key getting rid of the cars because
i've said for years now that key is
absolutely vital to benefit in terms of
its attractiveness and yet we put a taxi
right one side then we have car parking
and now we have over the still taxi
ranks another line so there's a lot of
three lines of cars between the people
and the river so i'm all in favor of
this uh just to test the waters and say
but also hopefully it will work and
other people will approach us and start
really doing something with our key
[Music]
and their main concern was they're going
to lose a couple of parking spaces and i
did one day i don't think they would be
actually children
they're not going to lose anymore
because they would have to work
somewhere slightly different so it would
be a very slightly longer walk to their
office than what it is now
because where they currently are
i think there's four cars whatever two
of them are is where the proposed cycle
of this
[Music]
so
i've got no one else wishing to speak
does this committee have to make a
decision on this formula
if we know the minutes of the hard
report which we can do we're there
right
that's the last item on the agenda
so i can declare the meeting closed at
10 30